for another stream this is gonna
probably be quicker than most streams I
will be accepting challenges so if
anyone wants to play me send me a
challenge I'm Lee Ches
I'm gonna try and not go more than five
hours today but we'll see I just joined
the ten minutes tournament rapid arena
just to get a quick game so far we have
a French defense rubenstein variation I
think the principle move is to play d4
just reinforce the center and I will
admit that I haven't really seen knight
c6 played too often in the Rubinstein I
more often the night goes to d7 to
support nine of six is here I can take
and black has to either take with the
queen of the pawn actually there is uh
I've had this position before there's a
couple traps which Bach fell into Bishop
g5 just traps the Queen I'm pretty sure
I had this like less than a week ago
like white just wins the Queen the other
trap is if black takes on d4 I didn't
take and then if Knight take there's
Bishop b5 win a McQueen so the best move
is actually h6 just preventing Bishop g5
but apparently not too many people know
to play h6 if there's anyone in the chat
let me know if the audio sounds okay if
you can actually see what's going on
earlier I was testing the audio levels
because like in recent streams audio has
been clipping a lot and like it makes
these really annoying noises so
hopefully it's better now hello DJ mercs
the first commenter thanks for watching
it's all good it's good to hear
if anyone wants to play me send me a
challenge on me chess because this game
will probably finish very shortly ok 49
s 4j hello you don't hear any clicking I
think you mean clipping so that's good
yeah I had to do some tests because I
think the game was turned too high and
the levels were the levels just were
wrong in OBS so this guy is sacking the
Queen for the night and I would like to
win this quickly I could take on each
seven attacking the Knights
let's do that I think it winds up on
I'll pre move Bishop takes you two just
in case he tries some desperado OMG yes
with the is that five exclamation points
it's a lot of exclamation points
challenge anyway so I have one challenge
from from turd a 15 plus 10 that's a
long game but I'm very tempted to accept
it
wait is turd in deduction the same
people Oh 49 s 4j s it's turd okay I'm
pretty sure you can challenge me if even
if I'm in a tournament because three
people have challenged me already
and hopefully this game ends relatively
shortly he plays bass Bishop e5 so I won
the H pawn let's drop the Bishop back
was my centralized square pretty much
preventing his Bishop from developing
and he also doesn't want a Castle
kingside here because he no longer has H
pawn so if he does castle
I have moves like Queen h5 the King
stays in the center I moved like c3 and
there might be some mating ideas on g8
how are you up a queen already yeah if
you just joined I'll go back I'll go
back for a slow-motion replay yeah let's
attack the knight c3 my opponent fell
for a pretty typical opening trap I've
had like so many people fall for this in
the French it's like Rubens scene
variation they like to bring their Queen
to f6 and then they don't realize Bishop
g5 is a threat and the sky the sky
allowed it I was glad very glad to play
it so he plays might be 5 and it looks
like there's gonna be some mating attack
maybe not forced mate but very close to
just something good came out g6
yeah there's no immediate mate but I'll
just drop back there's ideas of g4 and
h4 yeah h6 is mandatory oh so many
people asking how I won the Queen yeah
so and if I have time you just do this
threaten Queen Yeats ooh Nathan f31 for
with the ten bits thanks very much
yeah let's just keep pushing points yeah
just to reiterate for anyone who missed
it h6 is necessary like when you play
chess you have to like look out for your
pawns threats in this case the threat
was pretty pretty medicine so I played G
for you sucks a rook let's take with
pawn just open the file I'm still
looking for means I can keep winning
material but okay mate should be coming
very close very very soon
now there's Queenie and Queenie a king
take g5 okay he resigns well that's nice
ending the pain I'm not gonna click back
to tournament just gonna pause and we'll
accept some challenges a hero wants to
play Nathan wants to play turd was the
first challenge I do want to accept many
people I'm gonna I'm I don't say this
too often but I'm gonna accept turd
because he was the first challenger and
I feel like playing a slow game but then
we'll get to some of the other
challenges let's play e4
Oh turd is saying hi twitch a little and
good luck oh it's gonna be another
French this is really exciting
so we're two for two on the the two
nights attack against the French defense
it's a great opening for white against
especially against like more amateur
players while he's playing the same line
I'm pretty sure he won't fall for the
same trap though I'm pretty sure he's
also watching the stream so okay he
plays C 5 C 5 is like a typical pawn
move in the French but I don't know if
it should be played so early
I mean first instinct is to play Bishop
b5 check just develop a tempo but then
he has Bishop d7
the other instinct is just to play d4
and just like completely open the center
let's do that I just want to open the
center before he has time to develop too
much I swear I'd better not fall for the
same trap yeah uh let's take with Knight
I have a very vague memory of one of my
first coaches showing me like this exact
position and just saying these Knights
are very strong in the center I think
that was a good time for Bishop b5 just
pin the night getting ready to Castle
and I could Castle right away but that
might lose a piece you might actually be
threatening to take and win a piece on
the on d4 so it's not gonna carry the
way
yeah the threat is real I could take on
c6 with a bishop or the knight but I
don't necessarily want to trade I could
defend my bishop with a move like a four
but again that's a long trades so what's
the best move here it's annoying like
whites ahead and development but black
is getting ready to liquidate this
Bishop e3 could be a move if Bishop e3
Knight takes e4 bishop take g7 Queen
take these having bishop take t4 that
looks very reasonable we trade a couple
miners but they'll be left with with
some more development still I could also
just take on c6 simply because play
positionally like a Knight takes c6
Bishop takes c6 we trade Queens my stake
on c6 again and he's left with some
somebody said pawns that might be the
like objectively best way of playing
another option I see is just Knight f3
just avoid all the trades may be
threatening 96 use all look like very
fine options Knight f3
or night be three the same ideas I'm
gonna play tonight of three I want to
keep all the pieces on the board i
blacks a little cramped already and I
don't want to give this Bishop any life
I also don't want to trade off both the
knight and the bishop because they're
still pressure and he has to worry about
Knight to d6 also Bishop g5 could come
in certain lines
I will admit I kind of forgot about
Queen 85 luckily I have Knight c3 so I'm
not losing a piece
hello dishonest John okay we're playing
Knight to c3
let me move I may have already miss
played this and black might get some
initiative here hello sleep is for the
weak misspelling sleep its three e's
over th okay i was most scared about
bishop before there but that's sort of a
relief so I mean what to do if you have
any threats I think just castle then if
he plays Bishop before um at least
there's no pin yeah let's just castle
intuitive move ooh
Napoleon Bonaparte the fourth Pittsburgh
verse sweats to rematch next week is
that even possible
so I know we're both were we both were
both locked in for the the playoffs but
if we're number one in two in the
division
well we won't play next week rights
unless somehow we lose and get knocked
down to third place
I guess we could potentially play if
something happens ok he's playing slowly
he's playing Bishop d7 so he's 2 moves
away from castling I'm looking for
something - just like prevent black from
castling I don't know that's possible
maybe some move to target the Queen
actually I have a really tricky idea I'm
gonna play Bishop d2 and I'm not gonna
say anything because I know he's
watching the stream so I'll look at some
comments uh
I'm Sophie do you remember me from USCS
what is USCS they so many different
chess acronyms I know that USCF is owe
us chess school only went to the u.s.
chess school like twice my life maybe
some vague memories and what what city
was it st. Louis or New York maybe it
was New York I will admit I'm not
remembering a Sophie from US chess
school but it's possible we encountered
each other oh the one in New York where
I stopped by for like half hour ok he
played Queen c7 which is a good move I
was threatening 95 and if he takes I had
97 so you saw the threats maybe I made
it too obvious
with my comments so I still want to keep
the initiative somehow
as he clearly wants to play nine of six
know what to do I could play Knight g5 I
don't that has any threats 95 mm
probably not
well they remove I'm looking at this
Queen c1 but again I don't know if that
does anything complete Bishop g5 Bishop
g5 that's still 906 I play my key for
what to do here why it's clearly better
but how to how to make use of the
advantage I have to slow play like
Bishop d3 maybe organize some kind of
King side attack what to do to play
Bishop t3 Bishop d3 ideas of night b5
artisan of Queen c1 ideas of Bishop f4
nothing seems too powerful though
I could also just improve the position
my Queenie to rock anyone and then rock
everyone just argue that White's pieces
are better but I want to do something
more active 94 9f 693 okay this might
not be right I'm gonna play Queen c1 I
just want to play Bishop at four make
the Queen moving in positions like this
are sometimes tricky because you know
you're better but you don't know at what
like the best way to exploit the
advantage and you're also playing a
weaker player so you want to UM you
don't want to get to melon time I think
I missed some comments Queen c7 is a
good news i Queen c7 was very fine when
his crew 64 streaming I have no idea
they were streaming yesterday but it was
it was a pretty painful stream to watch
yesterday h4 h5 h6 I don't think I want
to be that ambitious
I'm not Simon Williams tends a stream at
10:00 p.m. Eastern interesting okay
feels bad man oh man sleep is for the
weak is uh I mean I do apologize for my
bad memory I'm terrible with names and
faces so if I encountered you in real
life and it was just like one time
it's maybe actually pretty unlikely that
I won't
I won't remember the name or the face
okay we're gonna play Bishop d3
avoiding trades Eric you hit and ran
yeah so I played them on Hamilton on
chess comm last night
and I know it like I only had time to
play three games like I was making a
pizza the timer went off and I didn't
want the pizza to burn and also I didn't
know he was streaming because I was but
was playing him in some like bullet
match and I figured I'd go on like chess
comm / TV to check if he was streaming
and it was showing someone else's stream
so I thought he was just playing like
casual bullets but then I've I was I was
told by someone that like he was
streaming against me and he was like
talking some smack but I did beat him
three three two zero before I had to
leave
it was not an intended hit-and-run but
okay that's the nature of making pizza
so I'm gonna play Bishop to f4 I make
the Queen move he plays Bishop d6 not
moving the Queen so decent move um I'm
gonna take it I think I'm okay trading
the darks friendships because there's
LightSquared Bishop is just bad and mine
is good and when he takes with Queen I
have rook d1 and you still can't castle
I think white saw me slightly better but
it's Pleasant Oh crew is in the house
interesting maybe we'll have to have
like a streamer versus streamer match
hello new here what's Eric's Eric
Rosen's real name yeah I have many real
names I guess
but yeah call me what you want
well the call a lot of people call me
mr. Eric for some reason like a lot of
students which just kind of makes me
feel old so he's thinking he probably
has to move the Queen again unless he
wants to castle which would be nice oh
he castles all these people hanging
there Queens today in the French maybe
he heard me and I said it was nice but
it's nice for white good game I mean he
was doing okay up until counseling like
if he plays Queen c7 here it's gonna be
a fight um real quick I I don't know if
I mishandled that or it was just equal
or compared with whites advantage
starting in this position I feel like c5
is Julius
so DeForest principal take take
ninety-six
so maybe Bishop e5 is wrong it's such a
natural move but after Bishop d7 black
wants to trade on Bishop III makes a ton
of sense here and if he trades up I can
take with Bishop and then this should be
fives in the air
there's also ideas of night b5 because
my rook is already defending the Queen
d6 as a whole okay lesson learned I am
going to move on we have more
challengers uh because Nathan sheared he
was only cheer on the stream we will
accept him and okay we'll see what
happens let's play d4 this game
I've been white three games in the girl
Manny just being nice to me with the
colors and good evening Mariinsky
welcome back
Oh sleep is for the weak is dragongirl
101 okay maybe I'll have to play play
this person just because we met in real
life and I forget meeting in real life
so oh crew 64 in the chat uh crew 64
knows will I play this is my favorite
opening just one one lesson here I
played Knight d2 before night of three
because if my knight was on a3 he would
have some ideas like 94 and it's
sometimes a bit annoying like 94
followed by a 5 so he plays b6 which is
probably reasonable I mean the place e3
sometimes idea b6 is to play Bishop a6
and C 3 is actually a prophylactic move
if he were to play Bishop a6 I would
take and play Queen a4 check so now
we'll just develop I will also note c3
is useful because if he plays he 5 I can
play Bishop d3 and I have some some
breathing room for the bishop this chat
is hard to keep up with the crew 64 can
uh can maybe help moderate Blue Crew 64
is not a moderator but to I want to make
him a moderator I have to hold off okay
I'm gonna play Bishop d3 a very typical
London structure probably going for 95
and castling this is my my bread and
butter
he plays 94 just probably a good move
because the Knights defended like this
bishops actually useful in the position
and now I have a choice I probably don't
want to take on e4 with the bishop
because then he takes it back and like
Knight has to retreat
so one move that comes to mind is like
Queen c2 but then probably f5 another
move that comes to mind is Knight e5 but
then he has f6 interesting what to do
Queen c2 f5 and then maybe I played 95
myself I have f3 coming let's do that
maybe even I want to like Castle
queenside get some King side attack I'm
waiting for him to play a 5 so I can
play 95 and a lot of things might get
traded here like we can trade nights you
can trade my bishop on g3 you can take
my knight on d5 so I'm ready for some
kind of transformation crew 64
predicting Aronian oh he's asking me
who's finishing top 3 and candidates I
would love to see an American player
either Caruana or buzzy cuz I will I
will probably be at the World
Championship match in London as a
spectator or a reporter it's looking
like over 50% so if an American is there
that would be really cool but I mean in
terms of likelihood it's hard to say
maybe Fabiano has the best odds if he
takes it seriously there's a lot
happening in this position I have less
than 3 minutes left and there's no
increment I could play f4 I could take
his Knight clayey you know f3 is bad
we'll just trade stuff f3 still bad can
take the bishop and then play f3 you I
can also play this let's do that because
II 5s week perpetual stalemate says
Kramnik Gramlich has the most experience
but I don't know I feel like it's not
gonna be chronic it could be chronic I
mean it's very close like there's no
clear favorite like no one was expecting
cardiac end last time let's play Knight
to e5 I'm envisioning a position where
he takes I take he ticks I take and then
I have g4 ideas in each thousands of
targets I might even try and like force
that line like playoff three next
I also forgot I'm attacking his queen
McQueen probably has to do something
okay Queen c7 very logical now he wants
to win a pawn so I can't play f3 I think
I'll just take I'll take in the Royal
Castle but which way does White Castle
he takes with F pawn which I'm expecting
probably Castle kingside
I gave up the Bishop parrot but argument
is my 995 or just the e5 square in
general is really strong for whites and
as bishops just bad on b7 but if he
takes with F pawn my file opens could be
double-edged well Castle if I didn't
Castle he had vision a six which would
be really annoying I might consider f4
at some point a very positional game and
whites probably not better but it's one
of these positions like the better
player is going to win there's some as
many imbalances for both sides and time
is running out okay how's the color
bishops some pressure on f2 my Queens
kind of stuck maybe I could play Bishop
d6 let's poke around I think he has to
play rock I see 8 to defend the pawn
I'll play Queen g1 going for g4
oh I don't have time for a queen g4 I
have to play Bishop g3 as rook on c6 is
really awkward as Bishop on g3 is
annoying but I'm pretty sure white can
play around it he wants the Queen trade
which I might just allow let's just rake
things put the bishop back on e5 in a
long game this would probably be very
Josh but in a blitz game was so little
time left the advantage goes to whoever
has more time which is uh just probably
mean which is definitely me but I'll try
and get some advantage before you flags
if possible but what to do f4 is that
for a move that for is a move let's
popping up something I'm before is it
move those bishops undefended now I'm
never mind uh okay I'm moving too slowly
I have to move quicker and talk less
it's like this move take me for you rook
g1 tactics
oh no tactics yet just want to win the
halftime as king probably has to move
here Lou tactics okay like something fun
I have three attackers on g5 this is
good I'll take that as Kings call off
let's do what when I wanted to this
that's uh that's free material okay that
was exciting
oh this is levy and levy has terrible
Wi-Fi
I'm sorry levy rx 1338 is saying boo I
mean I was I flagged him but I also got
a winning position somehow and that's
the nature it's like what to do in that
position he played well this is actually
a very fine line against the London SB 6
idea if you look Curran as Blake b6
Bishop e7 94 it slows down any any
initiative from whites I don't think he
was bullying you that's a good way to
look at it yeah I think for them I mean
for most of the game it was probably
equal analysis for maybe Bach was better
I don't know if any way to get some
advantage here
c3 I was just hoping for Bishop a6
clearly he was not gonna play but yeah
94 good move 95 I 5 I didn't want to
take home d6 because you could take back
with the pond and I don't have the e5
square in deduction do you think that's
the idea of f6e 5 is better than a 5
uh no because he needs to support the
Knights and there's just no time for f65
even if there was time it would take too
long because I have three attackers on
on e5 I mean if he tries to remove the
bishop there's problems with h7 like h6
i could play g4 g5
so what happened the game yeah it was a
fight yeah black should be better here
because this bishop actually found a
nice home and because he controls f1 it
was harder to defend f2 so maybe had
some ideas of like doubling up he
probably shouldn't take his rook f6 work
maybe what got six just rook of eight
and maybe like pawn storm looked kind of
scary but then okay then time scramble
happened and yeah dirty stuff anyway
let's move on a lot of games Wow I do
want to play subscribers which I think
there's a few is a dragon girl still
channel I'll play dragon girl if we if
we actually met in real life
hello again I think today I'm playing
slower games unusual the other viewers
challenged scream I did I was doing a
lot of blitz ooh I wonder if she'll
allow me to play dragon against her cuz
that would be exciting this is very
exciting
playing dragon against dragon girl
I don't usually play the dragon but
every time I do good things happen that
is a provisional rating which is always
unsettling needless rating okay
decent puts player
so someone taught me the sign I'm not
gonna say who but they taught me a very
simple way of playing Marat see behind
his back and I have to remember I think
okay we start with d6 it was some simple
setup like Locke is supposed to take
ours a Bishop d7 first maybe its Bishop
d7 first I know at some point we take it
play Bishop c6 and then 97 have to uh
I'll have to review this because I
studied this over the summer and it
looked like a nice kind of comfortable
cut line for black I will also say that
this is one of my favorite openings for
white because white just get some nice
face advantage but if black knows what
he's doing it should not be too
uncomfortable and I apologize for the
barking in the background my dog is just
getting really excited for some reason
yeah I've never seen a white play like
this a king h1 and Queen d3 this is new
for me
I assume the idea is to play at four I'm
just gonna continue I actually had a
similar position in a bullet game the
other day and in the Bullock game like
my opponent played b4 I played 97 and my
opponent played b5 I made Bishop got
shot it was really sad White's going for
a regression like usually Marazzi mind
is more positional like white just tries
to clamp down but it's at four move
might be some King side attack
Inc in this case blocks going for a
positional play
I'm just happy with my knight in Bishop
where they are queen d4 check that's a
move I'm a little bit curious about g5
here any fives usually just a terrible
positional move for black the point
would be if oh actually it doesn't work
if take I was looking at 96 but then
Queen take t6 so I have to play King who
became g7 B for the very worse tonight
to e6 okay yeah King G 8 B 4 is a little
bit scary but 96 the Queen moves and I
played B 6 I think because Black has
already played or has already traded off
a few minor pieces a position is more
comfortable even though it has a space
advantage my pieces actually makes sense
in the position and white it's kind of
left with this not-so-great Bishop to be
fair the bishop could go to a3 but I'm
gonna stop talking because I want to
give her too many moves if she is
watching Eric went 3-0 verse Mon yeah I
went 3-0 and then I ran away cuz a pizza
was uh
was cooking in the oven before is played
so Knight d7 runs them to be 596 it's
probably the only move
the Queen's gonna move and then the safe
misplayed b6 there's also this move 85
but I don't know
a5 a5 b5 Bishop g7 f5 could be coming my
night just feels really misplaced here
Queen b6 is also a mood makes a game
really positional it looks really ugly
but maybe it's playable there's a lot
I'm calculating there's like one reason
why it might be bad which I don't want
to say some I play it anyway I don't
think Queen b6 is playable okay I'll
just say it Queen b6 Queen to b6 886 and
then B 5 number 57 95 I'm talking my
pawns
yeah that's life
b6 right away mm-hmm
maybe I just have to reroute the nights
I could play rook e8 rook e8 9 f8 that
looks wrong if I was opening though what
else to do
b6 f5 move looks so scary I can't really
play f5 myself my dogs still barking ugh
I play Brooke I don't know what c8 it's
already difficult why did I play the
dragon I was so excited but now it's
just painful to do b6 doesn't work
actually wait I have an idea
Queen b6 quintic pawn to b5 rook a3 and
night b1 and then rookie 3 does that
actually work
taketake rook a3 takes on c6 takes on c3
takes on b7 rook b8 if 91 working you
three take on c6 take on you to take on
b7 rook b8 maybe it's playable Queen b6
take take v5r okay 395 we just trade
looks risky but I'm gonna go for it I
feel like if we trade Queens and it
becomes positional I feel like that's
where my strength is in terms of just my
own personal chess but also in terms of
the positional elements because when
Queens come off the board there's no
King side attack and especially at the a
file can open its one source of counter
play the original line was take take b5
followed by 95 that's why I had rejected
it but because of this rook a3 kind of
in between move I think it's very
playable and I think white has to trade
Queens what else to do I mean there's
Queen h3 but then queen take before
we're probably not enough conversation
I'm missing stuff in the chat but I
don't think it's too important okay I'm
just gonna focus on the position ochio
me H is in the chat hello Kiyomi I'll
come back yeah the chat becomes hard to
focus on when I there's so many people
talking oh thank you hero hero hero hero
for the just language reminder like
please be considerate with language use
okay let's focus back on the game we
trade Queens
I mean White has other options here
White doesn't have to play d5 but if the
bishop can say on c6 I'll be happy when
b5 is a very big trade off it kicks away
the bishop but really like weakens the
c5 square also makes the C pawn
backwards
I remember I forget where I heard this
was many many years ago maybe some book
or some coach saying like in the Marazzi
bind if light can keep all the pieces on
the board then whites just better
because white has more space but if a
lot of trades happen it and it goes to
some end game then black should be
better because white is sometimes
overextended especially with these two
pods a three looks like a reasonable
move I'm sure maybe she overheard my
calculations didn't want to allow her k3
okay so 95 are actually b5 in 95 are
coming so black has to do something
94 looks very tempting 94 and maybe even
following up with like a 5 I'm keeping
initiative there's a few different ideas
like box running to win a pawn
there's also night seed to ideas like
this might could be very annoying for
white all these different targets but 53
is reasonable there's might be three
here 93r okay - she's still threatening
be 595 kind of looks like it
so maybe just a 6mm okay this is turning
into blitz debating between either u6 or
e5 split six just restrictive chess
maybe later I'll play e5 but for now I
like the fact that this light has
nowhere to go
and now if b5 I can safely drop back to
g7 a lot of times when dragon dragon
positions especially a six can be
beginning for the d6 pawn the d6 is hard
for white to attack
so we're cuffed e1 very logical if I
play Bishop a4 I take a forward rook
take a four mm-hmm let's do it
going with instincts I just want to make
the rook move if she doesn't want to
take on any for their work has to move
somewhere else and I want to keep my
knight on d4 most importantly I guess I
could creme of this guy there's no like
tactics like I take a forward will take
a forward bishop see - there's a knight
take c2
also opening up the see file like maybe
rook c8 ideas because the C pawn could
be attacked multiple times it should be
three ideas - okay this is looking
enjoyable so I currently have ten
pending challenges which reminds me of
the other day where I just stayed
streaming for like over five hours
trying to accept all the challenges and
then they never ended so I haven't done
this yet I'm able to do this subscriber
room stream chat how I open up both
rooms at once twitch have to make two
windows it looks like okay subscriber
[Music]
okay just kind of PSA if you are a
subscriber and you sent me a challenge
let me know in the subscriber room it
just makes it easier for me to stay
organized
I think only subscribers should have
access to the subscriber room if you're
not a subscriber and you send me a
challenge there's still a chance I'll
accept a lot of pending challenges here
a lot of its challenges which is good
okay so I have a time advantage which is
nice
I think Bishop 84 was a pretty strong
move it was why white has a difficult
choice to make pissed where is a
subscriber room I say that right I don't
think I pronounced that word right you
have to go to the rooms tab above the
stream chat and it should be there it's
like on the top like above the cheers
anyone here oh there's also a moderator
so many rooms cool
if you challenged me let me know your
let's take that night your VHS username
okay I'm really liking this position now
so my work I think it for is really nice
not envy for is really nice this a three
pawns week this bishops not so good D
force coming rook fa8 is coming make
that green White's rooks are pretty
passive this is a positional chest I was
hoping for and I don't know what white
is really trying to do in this position
I gotten pretty sure my next few moves
like a five and rook at eight maybe
you're okay first those White's gonna
have some issues defending a three rooks
e1 wasn't a knight b3 rook be one
doesn't really help anything it's for
okay to like rook a to or okay eight
rook a one maybe I have night b3 there
but then Bishop C to take take take
well regardless situations good White's
passive she plays rook a to probably the
best move I'm gonna play rook a it's
pretty much forcing or k1o not forcing
or k-19 is attached let's play e5 it's a
nice example of a good night versus bad
bishop
and usually if White's playing the
Marazzi vine this is a one-piece that
one wants to trade off it's a light
square bishop so now there's some
decision like complete rookie three or
okay one actually rookie one lay Rendon
tonight be three now and then right back
to D one I'll have to be a little bit
careful how I how I try and convert and
she also might just like take on e5 oh I
also forgot I'm threatening a rook take
before which it's a good time to realize
where it take before is a move
was that just wins upon one pawn is a
lot in that game so I fade the dragon
for like the exciting attacking
positions but it turned out to be very
positional game I really didn't like my
position maybe about like five to ten
moves ago but maybe Queen b6 was a just
a nice resource for black so comes
Lachman another pot might be tricky
might as well throwing this move
d5 should be helpful
I'm expecting b5 is not the bishop is
just really really really sad play
Brooke f2 we trade mm okay I'll play I
have an idea rook F to my forced to
trade and I could use time to my
advantage as well
expecting team Ji Won the idea is to
move back to a2 just to cut off a file
and this rook really has no entry points
into my territory
there's to open files here I control one
of them another one's blocked by the
Knights and the plan is just to walk
that came to c5
just leave my rook and Knight where they
are
King bee - don't think the white king is
gonna be going anywhere kingi one okay
to do is when I play King g6 his rook F
one which I don't really want okay I'm
gonna do this first she'll play rock f1
oh she won't play rock f1 I was
expecting her again
mmm
King c5 rook F lon
I don't want to leave my F pawn like
that I'm just gonna play h5 maybe
improve the structure a little bit on
the Kings side and probably h4 it's
clamped down not giving the King any
breathing room on the H pawn is uh
pretty well can be well supported if
necessary maybe like F 5 F 4 it kind of
helps the bishop though
or does it I 5 taketake worketh 1 and E
for that looks nice yeah it's just about
making progress really trying to cut
down on the counter play from white and
white flags
yeah the line I was looking at is this
if take take rook F 1 whoa bishop take
out 5 I didn't see that oh there is hope
for whites it's still better for black
I completely forgot about they should
take outside but King C 5 Bishop d3 mmm
black still pushing for winning but that
was kind of careless maybe I had to put
my king somewhere else I do want to put
my king on e6 because a lot of c5 ideas
a Bishop c4 but interesting game uh if
we go back I think if you're playing
this is white you should know the
opening deeper it seemed like white only
knew to like this position and didn't
know too much further I would recommend
maybe playing f3 f3 or queen bee to f3
and then if take take Bishop c6 I think
this before move is pretty strong with
idea that white is preventing 97 because
of b5 that's a bit trickier for black
and scores well in the database too
but King h1 seemed a bit unusual but
seemed like white still gotta find
position many masters games yeah I
probably nice Keef I was just a bad move
because it allowed Queen B 4 and B 4 so
a5 is probably the move to play here
I was not feeling so good in this
position because the 996 is so awkward
and not 5s coming be five and ninety
five ideas for Wyatt
so Queen b6 was my one hope and somehow
it worked out but King each one was a
good move for lights
yeah maybe King h1 iff white is going
for a four then it's it's playable yeah
I'm curious like it is black equalizing
or maybe White's just slightly better
take take ooh a 4 or a 3 but yeah this
line with b5 yeah rock a3 kind of saves
a day otherwise white is much better
maybe white was still better in the game
push of d3 so maybe you're up t1 yeah
allowing this Bishop a4 move it was
really the root of the problems cuz it's
all up the slice blockade and then a3
was just a long-term weakness I don't
think that's a real penguin GM pretty
sure it's not I don't remember a 1-2-3
next to the game but hello - penguin GM
1 2 3 welcome to the stream a 4
yeah a 4 is a good positional move just
preventing Bishop a4 and it would be a
fight from here right my nice nice but
White's managing to play around it okay
[Music]
we will move on I'll try and accept some
more challenges I have 13 pending
challenges that is a lot Oh penguin Oh
penguin GM one is tank okay cool
a hero hero hero hero hero okay is he
challenging me still he is I'd also like
to try and play people that I haven't
played before but will give hero the
game last game he drew me in like a
really bad position so this game I need
revenge and we'll play well play already
okay
d5 let's play c4 seriously you're
waiting I've been white I think this is
a third game out of four games and I'm
white I'll play g3 I usually play these
structures as black so this will be
different I'll go for b3 it's one of the
few lines I've studied a little bit from
the white side going for some kind of
reverse Benoni like c5 actually forget
the move here do I play Bishop b2 first
or do I play e3 first
I think III first that might be wrong
split you three first should I go with
intuition I did the idea of III is that
if black plays d4 I can take take and
then I haven't committed my bishop so my
bishop could go directly to a3 but 96
okay yeah this is just a new opening for
me now I remember there is one game
between Kramnik and Mesa but I think it
was a difference
was it a different move order some
really cool Kramnik game I guess I don't
mind playing like reverse Pinocchio if
he plays g4 I'll take he'll take C pawn
and I'll play rook e1 just for 1985 oh
maybe this is still the kramnik Mesa
game I have to look that game up
afterwards so I remember like something
happened where that took and it was some
some interesting structure I may be
crying I played some f4 move neither a6
doesn't seem right b6 was a main move
there what is a6 just seems weird but
what to do complain Knight c3 maybe
Knight c3 of event e4 to play d4 myself
Queen e2 still
at brookie 1 I could take and then play
d4 oh maybe if I take him I play d4 you
played c4 and he's ready to play b5 hmm
93 could be a move but there's no time
to think I'm gonna try and stay flexible
I don't want to commit to anything
Queen e2 looks logical may be preparing
Murphy 1 in d4 well he really wants to
play b5 but now I can I think I can take
and play d4 because my Queens guarding
c4 if he takes with pong I'm
guaranteeing some iqp structure if he
takes with night it's a different
position Kramnik has played a lot of
cool games
oh and hero is still in the chat I don't
know how to play this is black I usually
play as this is white sign is a 3 B 4
rook do you want interesting yeah
playing d4
so now like if I want I can take and
this is gonna be an i QP I guess he
could play b6 here then he might like
got hanging pawns but I think the plans
gonna be pretty simple like just Knight
c3 bring the rooks towards the center
maybe 95 some day looks like a nice
position of her blitz b5 got space for
black and looks okay okay
yeah b5 was possible if he played b5 I
would take to avoid c4 let's play this
always a good idea whether you're
beginner or higher level player put your
work on the same file as your opponent's
queen good things will happen in this
case the Queen doesn't have a great
place to go I think if it goes to c7
I'll put thought I'd work on c1 then
play h3 kick the Bishop Bishop g4 is a
little bit annoying there's now if he
takes on g4 wait if he takes on before I
just take his Bishop that's a free piece
right as I say if he plays Bishop h5 and
then takes on d4 I wouldn't be able to
take with Knights but that was a nice
gift
yeah my subscribers are usually the most
generous people I'm very thankful for me
it's tough he waited so long to get a
game and he just hangs a piece but
that's life I mean tick oh he got some
cop
I take g-force coming but it shouldn't
be too much
90g for probably queen f for mean
White's up a piece for two pawns ooh
killer Cass is he's all beat chess
master lots of challenges okay whoa
bishop
I didn't even see his rook was on the
e-file but it is I'm really tempted just
to take on y8 and played to miners and
rook against a queen but I think I
should be civilized
it's Queens you to not give him anything
Oh Nathan f31 for would you be
interested in playing a much faster game
so I already played Nathan I already
forget I'm pretty sure I played him well
he's being aggressive 94 oh I could take
the bishop and have three minors against
a queen do I want to be like unhinged or
do I have to do it i could play Queen c1
queen c1 is Bishop c5 but then I d4 I'm
gonna just be be solid I was very
tempted to take the bishop though that
looked like it would be a fun position
hey Eric plenty me no don't do that
don't go for that well Queen b6
interesting
there is initiative here like this is
what we call accidental compensation
like he blundered now he's accidentally
getting compensation for it
he's frightening they take g3 as well
just being annoying but 94 looks like it
should solve most problems 94 take take
right no time to think I just want to
like trade and simplify and be happy oh
I could have just probably taken the
bishop right I mean take f2 stuff was
happening take with rook Oh
Bishop c5 ah wait no I can take wait
what's going on here take take what is
going on why not winning this Bishop c5
take well I got two pieces for the rook
mmm it's not what I wanted I have to go
for it
take take take take okay
it's really not what I wanted
how is he coming back well I didn't see
that weights this is really bad I'm one
time take-take-take
this is really bad
please don't kill me please don't kill
me please don't kill me
this is really really really bad I don't
know how I let that happen I need some
miracle
whoa
I was unexpected I can take with Brooke
and then take here I think he missed the
wind somewhere there well I don't want
to do that I can take the pawn and then
do this then this it's a time scramble
is the time scramble
please flag just flag please let's do
that defend and then this defend with
king and my king so centralized I'm
attacking of seven and defending my
bishop trying to get some coordination
here it's been a pawn well let's win a
rook
Hey ha ha that was an interesting finish
I quit I'm done good night yeah this
looked pretty ugly
you should not trade Queens I know he
was trying to simplify him maybe he was
calculating some line like if I take
with King oops let's go to analysis
board yeah of course he might to take
and that would have that would have led
to some probably very grinding endgame
where I would try to somehow win with my
two miners
but yeah when you're like massacring
your opponent's king don't trade Queens
like Queen I for I think this is I mean
this should just be crushing because
Knight f19 f1 is like double check and
then Queen h6 would be lead to some kind
of mates I think I was gonna play Bishop
c1 here but I mean of g-force hanging I
was not gonna survive this yeah cuz like
what does white to my King can't move my
bishop can't move my queen is stuck yes
I could play Queen d1 but then he came
taken with my queen at the very worst uh
you know me not for there's another line
Queen c1 but then I I thought there is
made here here here maybe not Oh Queen
f2 is yeah that's crashing okay if we go
all the way back
of course yeah I just played Bishop h5 i
think White's slightly better like maybe
plus point two or maybe more okay around
that vicinity plus 0.3 fish I do want to
find the Kramnik nice to game your
Bishop b2
yeah b6 is it it's somewhere here Knight
c3
I mean crab necks played this before I'm
just gonna Google a kramnik me stuff oh
that was an old tab I was looking at the
elite chess clothing store because they
have interesting stuff okay let me copy
that how do I import a game I have to go
to study new tab and then you study
I just want to import URL chess games
please be the game I think it's this
game like if you're playing this line
for white you should know this game oh
and thank you hero for giving me a
hundred bits even though I beat him very
kind of you
yeah this is a game so what does white 2
against 96 III so a 6 is a lot more
better I guess yeah just what I played
Queen e2 so I just want to review this
game quickly cuz it was somewhat
positional but then kramnik did like
kramnik stuff like this shove a
one-night 84 oh he went for d4 like all
these moves like he's doing weird stuff
with his minor pieces like maneuver is a
nighty for this bishops still pretty
deadly especially after d5 Wow oooh this
bishops overworked f5 you just sacked a
piece but he's threatening maiden to
mankind next so good 97 threats
efore Oh black was finding mates
your swings all upon's
wait why did black resign maybe Queen
each side or Queen h8 coming
yeah that's force mate here here here
MIT that's cool
or if kini eights waking he ate oh
there's this if kini seven is queen of
seven me and if this is this and then
Snow Queen f7 okay okay that's cool
I've oh I still have a lot of pending
challenges I have fourteen pending
challenges let's play someone new who
might want to play I could just accept
someone random I could play hyperbola oh
you know who I'm gonna play I think I've
yeah this name sounds familiar I think
he wrote to me wanting to play me on
chess calm and I told him to just
challenge me on the chess
so here we go playing Mike I don't know
this is his last name but it's it looks
pretty impossible to pronounce I'm just
gonna stick with some solid names o or
whatever he allows yeah we'll go for
Bishop before when he's playing very
classical chests so far hopefully this
will be cleaner than last game let's go
for d5 just complete mainline nine of
three now I think the absolute main line
is c5 there's a few variations here
there's a Karpov variation and Karpov
variation of c5 and then we take and use
stuff there's another variation I'm
gonna play the slime with b6 hero hero
hero I was in a completely losing
position
I missed a winning move mm-hmm I mean
after I won the piece it was completely
winning and then I I allowed the
accidental compensation it's been a
while since I played names oh it can on
line or over the board but okay this is
a few lines I know in the news oh I
don't think I've seen a three before
usually white takes let me get some
different structure here it's very
tempting to take on c3 also tempted just
to play Bishop d6 let's play Bishop d6
do you have any tips or guidelines on
when to fianchetto I think I think
that's how you spelled it or it spelled
Bishop's when I was in third grade I
joined a spelling bee and fianchetto is
like on the word list of like words to
know when it comes to like like fie and
shadowing in general I don't feel and
shadowing is a word like the active fee
and shadowing I don't know but it
usually depends on the opening and it
depends if the diagonal will stay open
like in this position the diagonals not
open but the bishop still useful on d7
because it helps support the e4 square
which can be very valuable for the
Knights but like in general terms it's
kind of hard to identify when to
fianchetto when not to fianchetto I will
say that usually if your opponent has
like a pawn chain I have he had pawns
I'm like G to f3 for my bishop wouldn't
necessarily be good on b7 or if he had
pawns on like D 5 and E 4 that would be
really bad on b7 so you want your Bishop
to contribute something to the position
before is a good move there I'm gonna
play a six stopping night be five also
stopping be five be five may have been
some position idea
lol you're playing Michael I am playing
Mike I think I've met him like once in
person like last month I told him that
if he wanted to play me more he could
challenge me online now we're playing
again I'm gonna start with Queen e7 here
if b5 then 85 yeah if he plays b5 I play
a 5 yes that's very true which trick
very potentially happen the nice thing
about box position is white can't easily
play 95 and is he wanting to play e4
here before I take I have four attackers
that's fine
I'll start with 97 so yeah white can't
play 95
I can play 94 so inherently it should be
just easier for Bach to play Thank You a
lustige old for the the five bits
appreciate it
that's one of the things I like about
the news Oh like that there's just a
nice peace harmony and a lot of these
lines and even if you don't know what to
do it's usually like pretty
straightforward to figure out where the
pieces should go oh and thank us else
duh what is that elastic hold for the
follow I don't know why I said before I
think that's how you say the name though
I'll play 94 and there's many more ways
for black to improve the position like
once an eye goes to you for now there's
at five possibilities 90 f 6r j e8 maybe
some potential for King side attack
we maybe even like Queen Queen e6 to h6
target the pawn so he takes I think is
reasonable do I want to commit to f5 I
don't know he has some idea of Knight to
c4 which could trade off the bishop I
don't really want my positive ended the
time being I could play b5 here that
might be a little bit weakening so I
really want to keep the dark squared
Bishop when I play b5 it allows him some
option of playing like maybe 395 but I
might just allow it my bishop can go
back to c8
let's do it another cheer this time for
more bits I don't know how many bits
that is but it's more than five ok he's
playing might be three yeah I'll let
them play nice e5 I mean if you keep
throwing bits at me and then I'll
probably play you I do appreciate them
just if you're gonna throw bits you can
do it all in one cheer and you don't
have to do multiple cheers of just one
bit okay let's focus on this position
I didn't play f5 because I thought there
were more useful things to do and
sometimes when you want to attack you
want to play some restrictive chess
first so that's what I was trying to do
with b5 because my bishops now happy on
g6
I'm just ignoring the knight on c5 and
now both bishops actually have some
scope against the Kings side there might
even be some ideas here of some like
quick I'm not gonna say anything
actually but there are ideas here to
completely destroy White's but if he's
watching I'll have to figure it out for
himself my username is sub ham 7 7 7
interesting where is he oh he wants to
play a hyper bullets ok I might accept
that I've been playing a lot of slow
chests today it's a lot more peaceful so
the thing I didn't want to say is that I
was maybe threatening this move some
great gifts I don't know if it works so
and I don't want to calculate I'm just
gonna play Bishop a5 quickly I probably
shouldn't have said that I'm threatening
it because now he might defend it but
yeah we'll see what happens
positions like this you want to not take
too many risks of course he plays h3 how
to attack I have more space on the
kingside I could try and sac on each
three somehow well I have a cool idea
let's start with h5 the idea is simply
to pawn storm maybe do this in this
open the G file that's a good move let's
play c6 I want to keep the focus on the
kingside hopefully avoid playing too
much on the queenside nevermind play me
five plus two okay let me finish this
game first I'm avoiding trading Brookes
she maybe some maybe that's a decision
to regret because I'll c6 is weak I have
to play I'll play rook c8 it's intuition
there's another idea here I kind of wish
I saw earlier but I'm gonna try and play
it beside the abyss of b8 and then
simply Queen d6 or Queen c7 because h2
is actually hard to defend if he plays
g3 and hangs h3 it also allows h4 so he
plays f3 but f3 I take you could take on
a5 but then I take on e3 and he has some
thinking f1 that looks so good I'm not
gonna calculate too much I'm just going
to play it there's got to be enough
ammunition oh thank you hero if that was
a timeout I mean if the person was like
sharing spammy links you can down them
but I missed what was said okay we're
taking on g2 and then Queen g3 and I
mean there should be enough comp or
better be enough comp it's 94 well I can
take very worst I win back material
I take the night there's song issues mmm
it's a weird position let's play Queen
c2 do you have to move quick I take the
bishop let's check again wait I don't
want to repeat what's going on here um
whoa I want a thought either I really
didn't want to go into this sign but
we're going into it ah bishop okay I
don't have much time trying so Lilith Oh
oh he hung his rook that's good
or at least exchanged I was tricky it
was too close for comfort
thanks for putting increment honest I'm
sure I missed something there but
somehow like 94 was very resourceful
because it looks crushing the King's so
naked but yeah II for and yeah when I
win back like
well I win the night back it's still a
difficult endgame so I'm still up a pawn
they're there any quicker win I didn't
take with rook because queen c8 king h7
queen of five I didn't think my king
could hide was king h6 Bishop c1 our
teenage six route 66 even yeah good game
Mike Mike ate something uh-oh why can't
I take the bishop maybe I could take the
bishop I guess I was just scared of like
Knight g5 stuff but I would still have
initiative yeah I should probably just
take the bishop I like I was about to
play some waiting move I didn't want to
commit to anything I was about to play
something like Bishop h2 but then I
freaked out because Knight c3 check wins
a queen but taking the bishop should
just be winning yeah me easier wind this
sign was still fast rate take two oh
it's minus seven oh I play rook e8 first
I'm nothing if he plays 94 I made into
okay
that's why move order is important I
have you see a move or if you see a
combination look at the same combination
but in a different order because I just
looked at this and rookie Yates but yeah
rook e8 first good to know okay I'm
gonna play someone else 15 cunning
challenges I do have to show some love
for the cheer so I'll play a place of
ham who has a different name in twitch
but I forget the name
o elastic hold okay good luck sup ham
I want to redeem myself I want to play a
dragon again if he lets me which of
course he won't play a six oh he's
playing closest note me wonder if he's
uh watch my video a four does stop it
stops B 5 but I don't think it's
objectively the best move why time
control so slow because I'm getting old
and I'm using a trackpad and I still
need to get a mouse I was actually about
to order a mouse today because someone
had sent me a link a few days ago but
then I couldn't find the link and I
wasn't sure which Mouse to get so I'll
actually use this as an opportunity
if anyone can recommend me a good mouse
for playing one minute or even like
hyper bullets or ultra bullet please
feel free to like send me a message or
share it in the chat Bishop g2 inviting
d4 don't let's play nice e6 for a night
at 6:00 pkmn is fun if you type in the
command exclamation point about you can
find that the answer to that question I
have been playing around with moobot so
there should be like new commands that
people can type in about is a command
uptime is now a command
I think there's supposed to be some
other commands too
what else did I set commands
man list oh yeah
me chest as a command okay let's focus
on this game also if anyone has liked
suggested commands I should add let me
know this is actually mimicking
mimicking some sort of like French
defense with this sort of structure
I play the h5 because I want to maneuver
in my knight to e7 and then f5 and now
allow any g4 push maybe h5 is a little
premature but oh I should add a stats
command to how do I do that stance oh he
played h4 that's funny he played h4
because he wants to prevent me from
playing h4 normally h4 is a bit
weakening for white because when my
knight comes to f5 g3 is kind of weak
and his Knights actually over works
I'm already threatening to win a pawn
and he doesn't want to take because my
bishop comes in so I don't know what
he's gonna do
Queen g3 interesting move it looks ugly
already for a white though like Queen b6
apply some pressure
you have to figure out how to insert a
SAS command whoa did I just blunder I
was playing around with moobot commands
I wasn't looking at the position I may
have just blundered my pong was
overworked just talking about overworked
pieces well that's annoying I'm gonna
try and get some accidental compensation
I think I have to take I have nine oh
six man the position was looking really
good for me too I should've played g6
just over defend the night let's go for
this attacking the Queen now Queen g3 I
think is the only move I don't know what
he's thinking here she could like Queen
g5 let's go for c4 actually there's
another problem for luck so my Knights
attacked and this pawn is ready to be
taken but okay there's a lot of
accidental or accidental compensation in
this position I'm realizing yeah I have
Knight g4 which is really nice some
initiative you might play queen up three
d5 still an issue there's a funny line a
queen before check Bishop d2 Queen take
B - oh wait Queen before check c3 never
mind
well I have a sneaky move very sneaky
move please save my paws now suggestion
cool let me actually record this I don't
forget copy and paste at least my time
situation is good there is increments he
plays a 5 which looks like I might win
upon but I don't know
well Bishop b4 c3 bishop take a five
Queens 85 Bishop c6 Queen take a 5 it's
a lot of trading just gonna scoot back
means this position is just probably bad
for black but my Knights happy there's a
pond you might be weak it's a slightly
overextended I want the bishop I'm
sneaky kind of move yeah just get any
optical corded Mouse I have to do some
research on Bishop c6 defense this is a
bad position and I've had many bad
positions today so I'm I'm kind of used
to it
high fives a good move I don't think
I've lost a game yet today so this is a
little bit concerning Castle queenside
yeah his a five font is actually very
strong I thought it might be weak but
it's being annoying and it's supported
by their Brooke the plan for Lux is just
to run the King like King safety and
then flag him Bishop g5 scoot over cuz
he is playing somewhat slowly and it's a
little bit awkward for a white cuz he
doesn't necessarily want to castle
either way I'm Bishop h3 very good move
I wanna play Bishop d7 I think it's
still okay whoa no it's not I'm losing
another pawn let's play f6 going against
the Ben Frank would rule but what can
you do that six was the only move I just
want to open the e-file or I want to
trade and open up some line no it's
actually some decision for whites cuz
yeah he opens a file my rooks happy his
bishops attacked he's still threatening
the Knights but it's not as bad I really
want to play Bishop b4 here I don't
think it does anything it's probably
just a bad move oh I have a sneaky move
rook h7
and you could take my pollen on g4 but
there's gonna be a file play whoo he
castles king queen side with his king
that was unexpected because now f5 is
more loose but my queen is just stuck
maybe I have to play b6 who I could play
rook yeah let's start with Rick e7
attack the knight and prepare 93 but
that he has rook to e3 mm-hmm rook to e3
I play Bishop a4 does nothing ok I'm
going for b6 have to play bit quicker we
can trade use up two pawns but I don't
care about these Kings side pawns I care
about meeting him mmm
let's take now the B file is open uh-oh
if it's gonna be useful for me
rookie four looks good
rookie for just win a piece just bishops
undefended yeah Wow
that kind of turned around this is
attacked I can defend
oh yes three connected pastors but I
have two bishops as nice still hanging I
could take the knight yeah that's
probably a good move
and now his Kings gonna be
having some fun with my pieces and b2 is
very hard to defend you could play d4 or
that yeah that was a tough game it was a
very good position for white until it
wasn't a good position for whites but
what can I say I mean yeah he he
shouldn't allow f6 once f6 happens black
becomes happier
so maybe Bishop to g5 should just not be
played
I probably Bishop h3 right away cuz I'm
if I play off 6 he can play b6 and then
he's either kicking my knight away to h6
or just winning winning something on g4
I was really happy with my position
before Knight takes e5 I should just
play g6 here it's very pleasant for
black and in deduction is asking how do
I say these positions I mean I got the I
get like really bad positions pretty
often so I'm just used to like being
worse and when you play so many bad
positions and you don't resign too often
then you just kind of pick up on ways to
be resourceful and fight back oh and
thank you elastic hold for more bits I
appreciate it
yeah time pressure was some issue in
that game I have a ton of challenges I
have 18 pending challenges xform 59
wants to play I should give extra me
game yeah I'll give xform a game I want
to just accept all of them but I'm tired
let's play before this game
wait I've never been next door and I
think the last game we played like it
wasn't even a Simon like you just beat
me what do i play it's just let's try
and destroy him good luck
let's play c3 don't play 906 he plays
minus 6
[Music]
ok we're playing some c3 cecelia in line
it's 5 oh so I'm gonna try not to get in
time pressure of this game Oh Chester a
chest steroid once it's imal I'll do a
Simon Asher stream I usually do like 1
or 2 cycles a week I take I think I take
I don't know too much Theory here I just
know that White's supposed to attack on
the Kings side but what to do oh I think
we've played this line before I feel
like I tried playing Smith more against
him last time too
and it didn't really work it's like we
need to this time last time I took in d6
early
it was funny watching you destroy Amon
and then leave yesterday I had no idea
I'm on was streaming until like
afterwards I mean I wasn't play the more
games but there was pizza that would
have burned in the oven and he went on
like a he went on some like two or three
minute rant on how I was like hitting
him and then running which I didn't
intend but I'm sorry he took it that way
it's play Rick do you want it's slightly
more positional but in case the defy
lever opens up his queen will be
slightly misplaced I'm trying to figure
out like how do I develop these
queenside pieces most effectively
because I don't really know I could play
Knight bTW - I guess doesn't hang
anything compares 94 so my bishop
currently hasn't like no good squares
who it allows Knight f4 Queen e3 way in
a minute Queen e3 Bishop g5 can't be too
harmful okay Queen III Bishop g5
shouldn't work maybe it's a move the
very worst I take the bishop and play
queen g3 so he does that
I do have to watch my time mmm I wanna
play nine of one button it looks not
defended which is annoying
so Bishop III I guess I'm playing very
strangely but maybe it'll work out oh I
see if she is in the chat I think if she
said hi or later and I didn't say hi
back
so hello - if she I'm very happy to see
g5 because now like the center is locked
I can focus on the Queen's or on the
Kings side I don't have to worry about
like calculating like these pollen
captures every single move so now it's
time to play quicker knight on c4 looks
aggressive I'll just play b3 though I'm
debating though do I play g3 or Knight
g3 both moves are playable probably
Bishop d3 first this mic looks very
misplaced
I would like to trap the night somehow
I'm gonna play my g3 rather attack with
the with Knights rather than pawns
there's some idea like Knight age five
and then what maybe Knight age 5 and
then g3 h4 I play a 484 looks nice
oh I didn't see that that's embarrassing
I was only seeing the night going
backward
luckily rooks don't mean too much in
this position because there's no entry
points on the C file and I still have
all my minor pieces to attack with so
again some accidental compensation and
if we avoid any sort of endgame then the
minor pieces are actually just better
than rooks but he wants to open files h4
take h5 e for tag take doesn't work I'll
play Queen e2 probably take with pawn I
have to get some time advantage last
time I played him I was low on time like
the whole game and I got a winning
position and then flagged or no I oughta
winning position got one time plundered
and I'm lost I have to look at the last
game we played cuz it was from some
similar opening that's play eh no still
h4 it doesn't work mmm rook e1 what to
do
h4 tape tape tape tape weights war might
work let's play h4 they can think
there's tactics where like he could take
and then win the pawn but I'm pretty
sure there's enough counter play for
whites Queen h5 stuff in the meantime I
just want to play h5 kick his knight
take back now now I'm also making him
think that's most important whether or
not he should take the pawn cuz it needs
like in these blitz games with both
sides having low time you just want to
make your opponent think so he plays
that she's preparing night at 4 it's
good idea I could take and play Queen d3
there's Queen c2 mmm and if my g5 right
away take take take take well I don't
want to trade but that line looks nice
let's do it oh I could take with Bishop
as well now maybe I'll take with Bishop
wait am I just losing a pawn just forget
about the e55 Wow okay well I have a
time advantage we're totally I can use
we are gonna take with the I don't know
I ever gets attacked this is really bad
I could oh I could take the Knights take
the knight first I keep the pawn
oh he takes on d2 though oh my gosh this
is really bad I'm just down the rook
here but I have more time I can't let
him beat me fairly a second time in a
row I play this looks like a decent move
more accidental condensation that's the
theme of today please take my rook
replace that mmm
Queen g6g six probably not good but what
else to do
I'm playing Queen musics I want to do
something I also want to make him think
more so stressful just please just flag
that would be nice okay now I can
breathe easier below 10 seconds
no increment now I can do this and there
mate somewhere I don't think there's me
but this looks good enough
cuz it's bit tricks now pin that's
running mate in one
wow I was expecting to end the game by
fighting him but well played like he put
up another good fight well I want to do
is open the game we played previously in
a new tab and just compare it to the
game we just played cuz I think it was
pretty similar
cuz I played some with Mora against him
before very similar line wait this is
just the same game wait what
no I opened the wrong game then wait how
do I go back to see our previous game
no oh if I go back here
oh I have to click on his profile and
then go to games we played yeah I opened
up both games at the same time games
games with me I want to look at the game
that we played was it just last week
wait what what is Lee chest doing I
clicked on mining here we go yeah so the
game we played last time I had like some
nice position and i blundered something
I've wondered e5 and then I was so a
long time so similar opening this game I
mean this game light was just better
until i blundered knight Knight c3
anything's fell apart
I should just play Bishop d2 here I will
get to challenges very shortly but I
just want to look back I mean okay
what's just worse much worse here and in
this position I think black should take
defending g7 it's good position okay
I'll move on good game extra 159 and
it's tough to keep up um ooh Daniel
Moreno challenged me I will repeat
myself from last time if there are any
subscribers who want to play me let me
know your your Li chests username in the
subscriber chat room because I am
prioritizing you guys first but in the
time that I have I want to play someone
who I haven't played before this name
sounds new pokemon is fun
we'll play pokemon i used to play
pokemon like back when I was six six and
seven and then I retired uh yeah good
luck D for opening debating what to play
let's play Kings Indian I'm not at all a
Kings Indian player but I don't mind
playing this from time to time
penguin GM one two three I'm not
avoiding you
I just have so many challenges to accept
that if you're patient enough maybe I'll
eventually play you
oh cool guy 2189 just subscribed cool
guy if you want to play me let me know
your username and thanks for the sub
Wow g3 I guess that's playable I'm just
gonna go with like in like Kings Indian
plans like a five maybe four if he lets
me yes I would have to play rook e8
actually maybe I can't play a four it's
92 would hit the pawn three times
I just realized I haven't been looking
at any of the follows but thank you
everyone for following me today I do
appreciate it sent me a challenge same
as my twitch name cool this could be a
queenless medal game if he wants to
trade queens or not I'll play Bishop g4
just attempting to get the d file and
there's no increment in this game either
so time management pretty important Eric
at the moment I'm Premium Member at just
24 uh wait what what advantage has it to
become Premium Member here yeah Lee
chess is completely free actually
there's a really funny link if you go to
Lee chess org slash is it features I
forget let me let me find it after this
game it's either Alicia org slash
feature early it's probably chest I work
slash features they have like a
breakdown of like the the perks that you
get whether or not you donate to them I
have to retreat rights okay this is
gonna be a fight might as well trade the
darts for bishops because that was my
bad Bishop that was his good Bishop now
I still have my good dishes and he has
his bad Bishop like Heaney 7 feel
somewhat equal and the only major
imbalance is like the difference in the
bishops I would love to get my knight to
d4 let's start with this
might take some time maybe night c5f six
some point I'll drop my Bishop back and
play 96 I guess that's the other
difference in the position that I have
the d4 swear and he doesn't have a d5
square but it's not a major factor in
the position that's an annoying move I
have to move quicker I don't know what
I'm doing here I just have to move fast
attack him
maybe provoke c5 might also be planning
a 5 in Rookie AIDS it looks interesting
I just want to like make some weakness
have something to attack take first and
then rogue AIDS check some initiative
but time is going to be most important
you may be winning a pawn maybe not whoa
to defend I still want to get my knight
to d4 cream of that let me trade and I
got a defended passed pawn hopefully d6
coming in make sure his rook can evade
can't invade this is the time scramble
but my passed pawns are stronger I think
you know I have some meeting attack okay
nice game good fights came down to the
time scramble I think the ending was
just slightly more pleasant just due to
the very small imbalances oh I apologize
if the stream was buggin sometimes
that's what that's what happens if I'm
playing like in sometime scramble we're
moving too quickly there's some lag okay
a cool guy I think he's the first
subscriber of tonight's I'll give him a
game rated 1300 good luck have fun okay
d4 let's play let's play c5 it's quite a
new opening and sometimes this is very
effective against players who played the
London because it basically prevents
Bishop at 4 I'm hopefully f5 I played
this a few times before online
it's the Benoni Dutch the Dutch combined
with Benoni two dubious openings joined
together into one also pretty dubious
opening Bishop g5 is a really good move
I would like to play g6 but then he
takes me well he just wants to take
anyway I played 97
ninety-seven looks wrong but I don't
know it reinforces the nights and
prepares prepares afine cat oh this is a
one thing about about this opening
specifically the benoni Dutch when you
have the bishop here and the pawns like
this the pawns do a very nice job at
complementing the bishop I guess that's
one of the things about the bodoni in
general is this bishop is just a good
piece meanwhile this bishop might take
some work to figure out what to do with
that he plays efore did he just play
Bishop e5 and then Bishop to e3 that was
nice of him I could play c4 here and
then distract his Bishop take the pawn
on e4 doesn't look too bad let's do it
some initiative uh yeah let's take here
well he didn't take the pawn so he moved
his Bishop from b-52 d3 to e2 being very
generous 94 oh he wants to play 96 and
my pawn is still hanging on c4 96 is a
huge threat so I'll play 95
unleashing this Bishop I was gonna say
he could have won the e4 pawn he's
probably gonna win a pawn back at some
point I could play Bishop should have
five looks interesting let's do it
it allows me I take out five but then
after do you take a five uh I think
blacks pretty happy there plays f3 and
so much happening in the center don't
know what's going on
take take one play Queen b6 let's take
first so I'm up now I'm up two pawns now
just one pawn c-4 still weak I've Queen
b6 Queen take b2 and start with that
I also have Knight g4 possibilities
Knight g4 could be deadly in some cases
94 I didn't see
what to do my g4 or just take on b2
looks like a free pond but I want to
play Knight g4 Knight g4 looks more fun
because I'm opening up the bishop so the
threat might actually be Knight f3 and
then Bishop take t4 I am allowing him to
take on e7 so things could they could
get messy but if he takes on e7 I have
93
it's a weird position is there a way to
go back in the video you will be able to
go back in the video once I end the
stream and then it's archived in twitch
you just click videos and they'll show
up there but I don't think there's a way
to go back during the stream unless I'm
wrong and then someone can direct can
correct me I want to play Knights ok
Knight f3
wait there's no increment I'm using too
much time I have 3 take take let's just
do it I think I have nine f2 in the very
end like he'll take on that 3 with
something I take on d4 with check and
then I have 2 happens and the pieces are
coming to life if King f1 there is my
page - this looks really nice winning
some material keeping my two bishops he
could win c4 but ok they're still gonna
be an attack on the King side and b2
still hanging I might just take b2 next
move if he lets me because I'm Rui
defense and he attacks
it's good move queen be something say
queen bee five attack the night you
might place III but then his night is a
bit out of play okay now I'll take on me
too
so he essentially gave me a free move
there I think a few issues for this game
that he's done is just moving as pieces
kind of back and forth and not staying
consistent with any plans yeah let's
take the Knights take back on that fate
ooh
takes on d6 mmm-hmm okay open file I
keep forgetting about time but okay
blacks up a rook here I should have some
King side attack Bishop take h3 already
maybe in there also just to move like
her teammates who also rocked a key to
is a threat I didn't even realize that
brooked a key to is the strongest
threats c2 still hanging it's always
nice
oh how do I get in contact with you
about teaching let me just share a link
on I'll share a link in the just our
personal chat what is that Bishop h5
he's just trying to confuse me and make
me spend more time I've rookie one here
if you want to get in contact with me
about teaching I'll just share the
coaches page take this
real quick I'll copy the link let's try
not to flag taken see - I'll do this and
just send me a message okay I'm making
this a little bit too close for comfort
but it's almost mates 10 seconds is
plenty of time should somehow be able to
capture g1 probably raffle incoming he's
almost promoting the knock whites and I
can remove that and that okay a good
game cool guy 2189 I didn't intend to
spend not much time but I think that was
uh ok it was an interesting opening and
he played Bishop g5 at the right time
usually with a structure black wants to
put the knight on c7 and not d7 so I
should have played I should have played
g6 first Eric I think you had 93 when
you play Knight f3 check mm-hmm 93 in
this position
93 is interesting because it waits what
does it do
I mean that threatens the Knights I
guess on g4 and it obstructs the Queen I
mean it's an alternative sock fish likes
it I did not intend 10 stocked fish
running but ya know the position looks
good for back and there's probably
similar ideas to what happened in the
game it's all about like taking the
night and then getting some future 9f2
to win material let's see what's a sock
fish like more right now 393 Bishop
takes he - ooh sock fish very strong cuz
just simple removal of the guard that's
a good move stock fish is good 907 Oh
the backward attacking move someone was
saying I forget who I think it was even
shook oh yeah I was in the Evod took
like interview that went viral
that he was saying the hardest moves to
see in chess our backward Knight moves
which I think has some truth just
backward Knight move attacking forward
in two directions okay well stocked fish
doesn't have any any trouble finding
good backward Knight moves
uh well I still have fourteen pending
challenges oh now only thirteen pending
challenges
oh cool guy just got them back into
chess five months ago nice
okay um we'll move on there's a lot of
people watching for some reason like
this past week there's been more people
than normal watching I don't know why
that's happening but maybe it's because
there is there anyone else streaming
right now oh there's someone else
training okay we'll accept another
challenge no I want to go with I haven't
done any Bullock games but no one has
challenged me to Bowl it it's all blitz
oh man okay I'm pretty sure this is the
same person who like messages me a lot
and I always respond to him I don't
think I've ever played him I'll say I'm
winging I do apologize to the people who
like challenged me and they're just
waiting to play me it's just so hard to
accept everyone that's possible that
this guy just isn't here
I'll give it like five more seconds one
two three four five okay I guess that's
also what happens maybe a lot of these
people challenge me and then forget I'm
trying to look for someone I haven't
played before let's play this guy I
think he's the highest rated player out
of all of them Wow such a nice comment
by some apodictic a strong player calm
voice instructional commentary no
annoying music I appreciate that comment
yeah if you guys want annoying music you
can just feel free to listen to your
music whatever floats your boat but okay
let's focus on the game
I had this position earlier against hero
but I played this as white and it was an
interesting game but now I'm playing it
from black side White has a few options
Queen c2 is that a move of I don't think
Queen c2 is great cuz g4 happens and
with d4 by the way I don't think the
Queen is that special on c2 I think Eric
needs some banjo music well I don't know
where do I find Angela music I'm just
gonna play like a reverse Benoni 96 if
he lets me play geef 5 I'll be very
happy but he might not like me
he has rook e1 here but actually if he
plays rook e1 I think there's very good
move Knight d7 because my deep pawn is
sufficiently defended and I still want
to play e5 and this is all about playing
restrictive chess a5 preventing before
I'm still ready to play e5 and one thing
about this opening is all the minor
pieces are still in the board and black
has more space so that should favor
black I almost always if you have a
space advantage and all the pieces are
on the board it will favor you he really
wants to play d4 so if I play Knight c5
he plays before and let's play for very
typical moves oh if I play Knight c5 it
loses this pawn so I would have to play
f6 so those are probably my next two
moves at 6:00 and midnight c5 if he lets
me Falcon punch 11 what are my favorite
variants all there than crazy house I
don't know if crazy house is a favorite
variant of mine I would say bug house I
mean over the board bug houses
is fun especially with like good players
c5 really you want he really wants to
play like night c4 Queen c4 I guess but
the spawns gonna be weak now I've
actually played a I played bug house
over the board with Aronian Kuryakin and
yasser sarah juan and also cara wanna
like about six months ago Aronian is
like one of the best black house players
in the world and he was on a team with
car yakin completely crushed like
everyone 94 good move
can i play queen 85 but then bishop deep
too I'm just gonna play slow like King
h8 no reason to spend too much time I
can just improve uh-oh
I am brick top is asking how do I
subscribe how do i subscribe to this I
think he means how do I subscribe to the
twitch channel moobot keeps advertising
how to subscribe it should have a link
if you have Amazon Prime you can
subscribe for free but there there's a
way to subscribe if you just like go to
my channel and click the subscribe
button I don't know how to be more
detailed than that but okay Bishop d2
question is how does black improve
further you see five is clearly weak but
it's also sort of strong I would like to
play f5 actually f5 is my g5 I'm gonna
play h6 sneaky move maybe thinking about
this oh I don't think I have a commands
command
unfortunately I'm still working on like
making moobot a beggar I was about to
say a better person but a better bot
when it comes to like commands and
providing information but it's better
than it was a few hours ago I think if I
play f5 night h4 was actually one move I
was a little bit worried about because
these squares are a bit weak yeah maybe
I shouldn't have allowed that because
after King now after I five there's 96
new wins exchanged teenage seven this is
a bit uncomfortable he need seven or
Queenie eights start with Queenie eights
preventing 96 I still want to play at
five actually but he of course stops its
but do I have some tactics might take c5
Knight takes e5 Knight takes e5 Knight
takes e5 this should take out five you
can take on b7 wait and I take C 5 1987
chess is too complicated for me what's
going on here there's mice are just
really annoying he wants to play 96 next
I don't think I can take on c5 unless I
can take take take take so many things
are hanging take take wait Knight takes
e5 987 take take take his 96 and 99 wins
a piece
I'm long time there's increment though
so that's good queen g6 here looks wrong
but maybe it's right g6 it's safer than
going for those complications
yeah maybe h6 wasn't a great move it's
too optimistic as Mike gets to d6 it's a
lot of pressure on d7 and this bishops
gonna be strong though if he plays
Bishop II for it I might have that five
his knight strong because pieces are
better than mine especially as I didn't
his Bishop yeah I underestimate that
this like all c5 move
I apologize for Automag rejecting one of
those comments Autobot does not like the
word analyze for some reason okay can I
add pissant but some pissant
when in doubt on facades but now what I
could play out five
oh man but b7s attacked this is really
uncomfortable now okay six maybe it's
player k-6 I still haven't lost a game
tonight
but I don't know how long the streaks
gonna last he wins b7 he has two bishops
this is bad mmm it's so passive but
necessary but maybe 96 coming and he's
playing quickly that's the problem I
don't even have like accidental
compensation go for f5 open up some wine
I mean it looks like he he might be able
to win more pawns bishops are going to
be better than my Knights this is really
bad kuba kuba kuba kuba will see it
let's play good move take 13 seconds no
passed pawn no Row two connected task
pawns
I just need to win like one pawn it's
very bad position I'm trying
nights are tricky I take no I can't take
well what do I do
ah that was just a terrible move uh take
that's was also a terrible move
I think Wendy if I was just crushing
well done I think it's time to resign
I'm just curious how he finished oh I I
lost on time yeah he played a good game
9h four very strong enough
did he play perfectly c5 also very
strong move if it actually works
did that work can I take with Bishop
maybe I just trusted him if I take with
Bishop mm maybe I could have taken with
Bishop uh because if he takes on e5 I
take with my see Knights I was only
looking at night take that's unfortunate
well with any loss especially a loss
like that I should go over the game does
he play the opening slightly strangely
Queen c2 is that an actual move master
is all set Oh Queen c2
third most popular move but pretty
uncommon uncommon based on the total
amount of games played quickly - easy -
I mean I like this position I've had the
structure many times before oh I didn't
mean to do that do I mess up OBS mm-hmm
I just wanted to see the timestamp but
let's bring it in a little bit more okay
that's better no that's still awkward my
bad what did I just do me yeah I do want
to see the time the time is like on the
right side and in order to do this I
have to resize a window just a bit maybe
make it smaller ah my dad but does that
too small people can still see the board
and people can see the time on the right
side okay
oh please accept my request again okay
let me just analyze this game for a
moment I mean he played very well
leach s comes with free opening book
yeah the leach s opening book is simply
amazing because it auto-updates at
filters of masters games it gives you
access to leach s like entirely chest
database to all the games I've ever
played on the chests I think so it's a
great tool
yeah he just completely crushed me h6
was just a bad move I was trying to be
too sneaky it was kind of one of these
hope chest moves like I was hoping for
f5 but not each for it's too strong so
Knight dp8 that's a really strange move
to consider but I feel like I thought
that came under my radar I probably
should have played it because it makes
so much sense like it's all about
finding harmony among the pieces it
looks just like it son developing but
the intention is to play Bishop e6 from
96 or even Bishop e6 and then Knight
back to d7 so that's a good move but
yeah after after age 6a there's any
coming back Queen g6 another bad move
and you just kept his advantage like he
played very well Queenie eights whoa my
advantage just K my my disadvantage just
kept getting bigger and bigger and
bigger
yeah this is where I froze up but
already it's +64 lights so what was he
made one mistake this whole game was his
one mistake Queen b3 sometimes that's a
little bit fishy but never know like
that's almost a perfect game on his part
b3 still a good move
okay we're moving on I have a lot of
challenges happening a subscriber room
anyone no okay
moderator room no okay we'll go back to
the chat oh that was a test okay I see
the test from here Oh stream chat uh
yeah that was a little bit fishy but all
I'm gonna look closer at this game a bit
later let's go back to challenges
there's an FM wanting to play there's
other people wanting to play oh man
and I'm tired like I don't know how long
I'm gonna survive for I am
yeah I'm just too tired I'm gonna end it
there I'm sorry to everyone who wanted
to play thanks all of you for watching I
will do like I'll be doing streams like
this every week so if you really want to
play me just be persistent or subscribe
and then there's a bigger likelihood of
playing me but um
I'm ending it there thanks guys for
watching I'll be back in the future
adios